would you rather take weight loss
product or stay as a plus size model
I mean calorie deficit works yeah
it sucks but it works like
um but I again I've said like I struggle
if I can press a button and just be
because you could say but I struggle
both you know if uh one is both
detrimental to you which would you
rather not eating and you know maybe
even the products that are forced into
calorie deficit or staying at an
unhealthy weight what are you taking I
mean I I
like if I could press
a button I would press it but that's
just not the reality for me and a lot of
other people and for me it's been a
grind and like I have been what do you
think what's the solution it's hard